REALLY BE SEEN AS A CURTLY
ORCHESTRATED A TIMELY BIT OF PR
FROM RUSSIA AS WE HAVE SEEN.
CROWDS PACKED INTO RUSSIA'S
OLYMPIC STADIUM REALLY
CELEBRATING THE ANNEXATION OF
CRIMEA, THE EIGHT-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THAT ACT ALL THE
WHILE WHILE RUSSIA IS CONTINUING
TO THREATEN THE TORATORIAL
INTEGRITY NOT ONLY OF EASTERN
UKRAINE BUT MUCH OF THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING THE CAPITAL KYIV.
WE'RE REALLY SEEING THESE QUITE
SHOCKING PICTURES FROM MOSKOW,
CROWDS PACKED IN, WAVING THE
RUSSIAN FLAG, A CELEBRATION OF
THIS ANNEXATION.
VIDEOS SHOWN REALLY CELEBRATING
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY.
BUT OF COURSE THIS IS IMPORTANT
TIMING FOR RUSSIA.
WE HAVE HEARD REPORTS FROM NATO
AND OTHER WESTERN OFFICIALS THAT
MORALE WITHIN THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY AND EVEN SUPPORT FROM
WITHIN RUSSIA IS WANING.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN PROTESTS IN
MOSKOW AND ST. PETERSBURG
AGAINST THE WAR.
SO THIS IS REALLY A SHOW BY THE
KREMLIN TO REALLY BOLSTER THAT
SUPPORT FOR THE COUNTRY, THE
MILITARY AND WHAT IT HAS
DESCRIBED AS A MILITARY
OPERATION IN UKRAINE.
OF COURSE THIS IS A FULL-SCALE
WAR TARGETING YOU SEE CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BRINGING THE
COUNTRY REALLY TO A STANDSTILL
NOW.
BUT OF COURSE THESE PICTURES
WILL COME AS QUITE A SHOCK TO
THOSE IN UKRAINE, SEEING THE
CELEBRATION AND ANNEXATION,
WHICH OF COURSE FORCED WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW EIGHT YEARS
AGO.
AND OF COURSE THOSE IN THE
DONBAS REGION WHICH HAS BEEN HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD BY MOSKOW'S
INVASION.
THIS WILL OF COURSE BE DIFFICULT
TO WATCH.
NOW, WE ARE HEARING REPORTS THAT
MEMBERS OF STAFF FROM THE
KREMLIN, OTHER STATE OFFICIALS
WERE ACTUALLY PRESSURED TO
ATTEND THIS RALLY.
CNN HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY THESE
REPORTS.
BUT OF COURSE THIS DOES FIT INTO
THE NARRATIVE OF THE IDEA RUSSIA
PUSHING THIS PR CAMPAIGN AS A
SORT OF LAST DITCH EFFORT AS WE
SEE THAT LOWERING OF MORALE
WITHIN THE TROOPS AND OF COURSE
A SHOW OF REALLY OPPOSITION TO
THE WAR BY PROTESTERS WITHIN
RUSSIA AS WELL.
ELANI?
>> YEAH, NADA, I HAVE TO SAY
IT'S PRETTY SURREAL SEEING THESE
IMAGES, THE CELEBRATION OF THE
ANNEXATION.
AND THIS HAS BEEN PART OF, YOU
KNOW, THE SORT OF RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA MACHINE IN TERMS OF
JUSTIFYING ITS INVASION INTO
UKRAINE.
WE KNOW THEY'VE BEEN CALLING IT
A SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION.
THEY CONTINUE TO DO THAT ON THE
PUBLIC STAGE, AND THERE YOU HAVE
IT, THAT IS PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
HE'S SPEAKING RIGHT NOW AT THIS
RALLY.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
TRANSLATION, BUT LET'S JUST
LISTEN INTO THIS.
>> Translator: AND THEY WANTED
TO BE REUNITED WITH THEIR
HISTORICAL MOTHERLAND, RUSSIA.
THEY HAD EVERY RIGHT TO DO SO,
AND THEY ACHIEVED THEIR GOAL.
LET US CONGRATULATE THEM ON THIS
GREAT OCCASION.
CONGRATULATIONS.
OVER THIS TIME RUSSIA HAS DONE A
LOT TO RAISE CRIMEA AND
SEBASTOPOL.
WE HAD TO DO THINGS THAT ARE
AREN'T IMMEDIATE -- BUILDING NEW
ROADS, NEW HIGHWAYS AND BRIDGES.
WE HAD TO PULL CRIMEA FROM THE
DEGRADING POSITION AND
CONDITIONS THAT CRIMEA AND
SEBASTOPOL WERE IN WHEN THEY
WERE PART OF A DIFFERENT STATE,
WHICH FUNDED THESE TERRITORIES
ON A RESIDUAL BASIS.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE MATTER.
THE MATTER IS THAT WE KNOW WHAT
TO DO NEXT, HOW TO DO IT AND AT
WHAT EXPENSE.
AND WE WILL IMPLEMENT ALL OUR
PLANS.
BUT IT ISN'T MERELY A MATTER OF
THESE DECISIONS.
CRIMEANS AND THE PEOPLE OF
SEBASTOPOL DID RIGHT WHEN THEY
PUT A BARRIER IN THE WAY OF
NATIONALISM AND NAZISM AND
EXTREME NATIONALISM.
BECAUSE WHAT WAS GOING IN THOSE
TERRITORIES IS STILL GOING ON.
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN DONBAS ALSO
DISAGREED WITH THE -- WITH THE
COUP.
AND IMMEDIATELY PUNITIVE
OPERATIONS WERE CARRIED OUT
AGAINST THEM, AND MORE THAN ONE
THEY WERE SUNK INTO A BLOCKADE
AND CONSTANTLY SHELLED.
THEY WERE SUBJECTED TO AIR
STRIKES, AND THIS IS WHAT WE
CALL GENOCIDE.
AND TO RID THESE PEOPLE OF THIS
SUFFERING AND THIS GENOCIDE WAS
THE MAIN REASON, THE MAIN
MOTIVATION AND THE MAIN
OBJECTIVE OF THE OPERATION THAT
WE BEGAN IN DONBAS AND UKRAINE.
THIS WAS THE OBJECTIVE, AND THIS
IS WHEN I THINK OF THE BIBLE.
THERE IS NO GREATER LOVE THAN IF
SOMEBODY GAVE THEIR SOUL FOR
THEIR FRIENDS.
AND WE CAN SEE THE HEROIC DEEDS
OF OUR GUYS IN THE COURSE OF
THIS OPERATION
.
THESE WORDS FROM THE HOLY
SCRIPTURE OF CHRISTIANITY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY DEAR TO
THOSE THAT PROFESS THIS
RELIGION, BUT EVERYTHING IS DOWN
TO THE FACT THAT THIS UNIVERSAL
VALUE FOR ALL THE PEOPLES AND
ALL THE CONFESSIONS OF RUSSIA
AND FOR OUR OWN PEOPLE ABOVE
ALL -- ABOVE ALL FOR OUR OWN
PEOPLE, AND THE BEST
CONFIRMATION OF THAT IS HOW OUR
GUYS ARE FIGHTING IN THE COURSE
OF THIS MILITARY OPERATION
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER, HELPING
AND SUPPORTING EACH OTHER.
AND IF THE NEED COMES, THEY WILL
SHIELD EACH OTHER IN THE
BATTLEFIELDS FROM THE BULLETS AS
BROTHERS.
WE HAVE NOT HAD SUCH UNITY FOR A
LONG TIME.
IT SO HAPPENED THAT THE
BEGINNING OF THE OPERATION
NEARLY BY ACCIDENT COINCIDED
WITH THE FIRST DAY OF --
>> ALL RIGHT, YOU ARE SEEING
LIVE PICTURES FROM MOSKOW.
WE JUST HEARD FROM PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN ON THE EIGHT-YEAR
CELEBRATIONS OF THE ANNEXATION
OF CRIMEA TODAY 18th OF MARCH.
AND I STILL HAVE NADA BASHIR
WITH ME.
I WANT TO REPEAT SOME OF WHAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN SAID, THAT
CRIMEA IS REUNITED WITH
HISTORICAL MOTHERLAND AND LET US
CONGRATULATE THEM.
AND HE SAYS WE KNOW WHAT TO DO
NEXT AND WE WILL IMPLEMENT ALL
OUR PLANS.
HE'S BASICALLY REITERATED AND
ALSO JUSTIFIED WHAT THEIR NEXT
MOVES ARE AND AGAIN SPINNING THE
LIE OF NAZISM AND THAT HE'S
THERE TO SAVE UKRAINIANS.
>> YEAH, ELANI, YOU HAD HE'S
CELEBRATING THE ANNEXATION OF
CRIMEA LIKENING THAT NOW TO THIS
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION HAS
HE'S DESCRIBED IT IN UKRAINE, AS
HE'S SAID TRYING TO RID THE
DONBAS REGION AS WHAT HE
DESCRIBED AS NAZISM AND
GENOCIDE.
AND THIS HAS BEEN PROVEN FALSE
NOT ONLY BY CNN OUTLETS BUT NATO
AND HUMAN RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
WE KNOW PRESIDENT PUTIN, THE
KREMLIN AND RUSSIAN FORCES ARE
TARGETING CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN UKRAINE,
THREATENING THE TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY OF THE COUNTRY.
GO BACK TO A FEW OF THE THINGS
HE SAID.
HE WAS PRAISING RUSSIA'S
INFRASTRUCTUREAL SUPPORT.
HE TALKS ABOUT THE HEROIC DEEDS
OF FORCES, AND THAT IS IMPORTANT
AS WE HAVE HEARD REPORTS FROM
NATO AND OTHER U.S. OFFICIALS
THAT MORALE IS CERTAINLY WANING.
WE HAVE IN OUR OWN INVESTIGATION
WITH CNN REVEALED SEVERAL
RUSSIAN TROOPS WEREN'T EVEN
AWARE THEY WERE HEADING INTO
UKRAINE AND TRULY BELIEVED THEY
WERE TAKING PART IN MILITARY
EXERCISES.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME APTIC DOTAL
REPORTS OF EVEN TROOPS
ABANDONING THEIR TANKS AND
WEAPONS THAT HAVE BROKEN FACED
WITH HUGE LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES
ACCORDING TO NATO AND OTHER
WESTERN OFFICIALS.
CLEARLY PUTIN THERE DRIVING HOME
THAT MESSAGE TRYING TO REUNIFY
THE COUNTRY, AND HE DID SAY
RUSSIA HASN'T HAD THIS LEVEL OF
UNITY IN SUCH A LONG TIME, BUT
THAT IS DIFFICULT TO BELIEVE
GIVEN THE FACT WE'VE SEEN REALLY
OUTSTANDING PROTESTS IN MOSKOW,
ST. PETERSBURG AND OTHER PARTS
OF RUSSIA, A REALLY SEVERE
CRACKDOWN ON FREE PRESS IN
RUSSIA AS WELL.
AND WE'VE SEEN SOME PRETTY
DRASTIC ACTION BY OTHER
JOURNALISTS IN MOSKOW, TOO.
SO CLEARLY THIS IS ALL PART OF
THE KREMLIN'S PRETTY TIGHT RUN
PR CAMPAIGN TRYING TO PUSH THEIR
NARRATIVE ABOARD AND HE EVEN
INVOKED THE BIBLE AND TALKED
ABOUT THE RUSSIAN TROOPS
DEFENDING THEIR MEN AND
DEFENDING THOSE VULNERABLE WOMEN
IN UKRAINE.
BUT CLEARLY AS WE HAVE SEEN OVER
THE LAST FEW DAYS WITH OUR
REPORTING AND IN WARNINGS FROM
NATO AND OTHER WESTERN OFFICIALS
THAT THIS SO-CALLED SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION IS A
FULL-SCALE WAR TARGETING
CIVILIANS, THREATENING THE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY